- We're going to make a song that
makes you feel like you
can conquer the world.
Because I had nothing when I was a kid.
Nothing.
I had my first job when I was 13.
You're not going to see me do things
that are the easy play.
It's just not going to happen, you know?
You're going to see me do things
that I have no business doing.
- Hello believe nation,
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe,
and I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems.
So to help you on your journey today,
today we're going to learn
from singer songwriter
producer and entrepreneur Tom DeLonge
and my take on his top
10 rules of success.
Rule number six is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired.
Might win a prize as well.
And also when you write it down,
it's much more likely to
stick to yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(upbeat instrumental music)
- When I was in the seventh grade,
my buddy moved away to Oregon.
There's a week where I went up
to go visit him in Portland.
Flew up there by myself, go to his house,
and the whole thing was is hey,
he's going to be in school on
some of these days this week,
so you can shadow him to school,
or you can hang out 'till
he gets out of school.
I shadowed him one day and I was like,
this is (censored) weird,
I'm going to stay at your house and wait.
But in his room there were
four things that were very important.
A Stiff Little Fingers record.
There was an All record,
a Dinosaur Junior record,
and there was an electric guitar.
So what I did was I would play
those three albums on vinyl
and I would go over
and pick up this guitar
to keep myself entertained
throughout the day
for those three or four days
that he would be at school,
and so he'd come back and we'd
skate at night and do whatever.
That changed my life.
You know, it changed my life.
Hearing punk rock music
and picking up the guitar,
something clicked where it's almost like
there's a bunch of gasoline on the ground
and someone flicks a
cigarette and it just ignites.
It was a chemical reaction that just
flipped on a switch
that nothing could take
that guitar out of my hand
from that point forward.
Being in a band, you have to
constantly reinvent yourself.
You have to constantly be reminded
how there's someone better than you.
Every other weekend.
And you're constantly reminded
how you would have
nothing without your fans.
So you have to take into
account what they're thinking
and what they're interested in.
And all those things matter.
But it doesn't matter what art you do.
Doesn't matter if it's making an album
or a movie or a book or whatever.
Thinking about all those types of things,
the hard work involved.
If you want to have like a casual life,
you don't want to be in a band.
You never sleep, it's
really really hard work.
You're exhausted all the time.
You're almost always sick and you're
fighting with your business
partners all day long.
It's just how it is.
But I have a very very strong work ethic
because I had nothing when I was a kid.
Nothing.
I had my first job when I was 13.
I had two jobs when I was 16, you know?
But I think a lot of it's probably
because I'm extraordinarily fearful
about having to do what
someone tells me to do,
so I'd rather be doing everything.
Because at least no
one told me to do that.
(host laughing)
You know, I don't know.
I think when you grow up as a kid,
you know you're always
looking for your voice.
You're always looking
for your independence.
to find out who you are.
With skateboarding,
it was a means of transportation
first and foremost.
As a kid if you have a
skateboard you can get out
and you can go somewhere.
You can't drive yet, you know.
So it's kind of like this is your tool,
your vehicle to leave.
And then you're kind of goin'
okay well it's my freedom,
but expanded from just transportation.
It's something you do on your own,
you don't need a whole
team to play it with you.
You just do it with--
And you can go skate by yourself.
And I think that music did a
lot of the same kind of stuff.
I think that when you're joining
a band for the first time,
you're trying to find your voice.
You're trying to find that freedom,
to get in a van and get out of town.
You're trying to figure out who you are
by defining it through your music,
the way you dress and
who you hang out with.
It was funny.
Bono once said that they didn't even know
to start the band U2
until they saw the Ramones
and realized you don't have to shred at
your instruments to be
in a band, you know?
You can get the emotion
across in a different way.
It was kind of more what you were saying
and how you were living,
not as much as your solos,
you know, on guitar.
So what I learned from
being in a punk rock band
was really these ethics
of getting out there
and doing things yourself.
I've always been fascinated with space.
I'd always tell people this,
'cause it's one of my favorite quotes.
If space is infinite, like there's no end,
there's no (censored) end to space,
then it's infinite the
possibility, you know?
Anything you think of right now
could be happening because it's that big.
And that was always really exciting to me,
'cause I'm kind of
wired to be an optimist,
and when I started playing guitar
with these types of
rhythmic trance-like echoes,
I started to feel that way.
I started to feel like I
was floating through space.
First thing I did was I set
up the studio in my house,
so I could be at home, for the first time.
And then I put up these
big television screens,
and I was playing all
science fiction films.
Like Blade Runner or 2001,
anything that was visually stunning.
But then I also had these
Steven Ambrose books,
these big coffee table books
with World War 2 pictures.
And I kept going over there
looking at the space movie
and then lookin' back down
at the World War 2 photos,
and back to the space
movie, and I was like, wow.
That juxtaposition is gnarly, you know?
Here's the Earth horizon and the
sun coming up and it's so beautiful,
and then here's guys in a
ditch, bodies everywhere.
And I'm kind of going,
is that the same place?
(laughing) You know, Earth
does both those things?
And I said, what it would it sound like
with marching coming into the song or
what would it sound
like if it sounded like
a battalion of tanks rolling
in as the song starts?
And Critter,
which was my engineer and
co-pilot in all of this stuff.
He pointed to a file cabinet.
And he's all,
just slam that file cabinet
shut, open and shut.
And I was like, all right.
And so he grabs a mic and does it.
And it's just. (creaking and slamming)
And you just hear the
mechanics and this kind of
grinding-like metallic noise with a slam.
And he put it in there and
he did his thing to it,
pitched it down.
The next thing you know, when
it's happening in a rhythm,
it just sounded like a million
troops stomping on your face.
And I was like, oh my God.
I've never heard something
like that in a song.
And next thing you know we're
doing that on all the songs.
We found something that was unique to do,
which was, you know, it's sound design.
You see it in movies all
the time, it's sound design.
But sound design crafted into a song.
And four songs into that writing,
we wrote a song called The Adventure.
And that just, that was a
life-changing moment for me.
We put some rocks in a shoebox,
and we rolled the shoebox
around with all these pebbles.
(grinding) And then we grabbed that,
and created a rhythm out of it.
And so when we added some stomps
and this rolling box of rocks,
it created this grind-y kind of rhythm,
and then we added a riff to it
that was a very simple riff.
Kind of sad sounding.
But I didn't know what I was
going to play for the main song.
So we started with the
rhythm, then put a riff,
then I was like, okay so
where does it go from here?
So I stomped on the pedal in time,
and I was for hours straight
sitting at the computer,
I think there's footage of this,
of the documentary we made.
Maybe you could show it right here.
(music playing)
Where does this need to go?
I could bring in some
rhythm underneath that.
I think that it's what happens right here
is what's throwing me for a loop.
- Right.
- I was sitting at the computer,
and it just kind of starts to happen.
(rapid guitar playing)
Here, it's a little dry.
On the song, in the moment,
it was something that gave you
the chills up and down your arms.
And I remember stopping
and looking at Critter,
and I was like holy
(censored), holy (censored).
We got somethin'.
("The Adventure" by Angels and Airwaves)
- I remember during writing
the words, actually,
that friend who's wife left him
just figured that she could
find something better.
And he loved her.
I remember him saying,
I don't know if you'll
ever know what it's like
to love somebody so much more
than they will ever love you,
is what he said to me.
So I remember feeling so beat up
from everything I was going through
with the whole Blink
situation and trying to
find a new identity and
all that kind of stuff,
and then my friend says that to me.
And I was like, well (censored) then,
we're going to make a song that makes you
feel like you can conquer the world.
That night after I sang it,
I remember sitting in the studio at 2 a.m.
It was at my house, my family's asleep.
And I was listening to this thing,
and about halfway through the song
I have these tears in
my eyes, and I was just,
I felt like there was
something magical happening.
That happens to me every once in a while
where I'm apart of something artistically
where I get kind of
overwhelmed emotionally
and feel like I'm really on
to something that's important.
Not that I think it's like great
or better than anything else
or that's it's going to
be something giant or big,
it's because I feel like it touches on
something that's important to me.
And it like grabbed a hold of like nerve
and just gripping it and I can feel it,
and it's like electric
waves through your body.
It doesn't happen on every single thing,
but it happens every so often.
And you kind of go wow,
this what I was meant to do,
was this one little thing, you know?
And that song was one of them.
- I think I learned over
the past handful of years
that what I really enjoyed about a band
wasn't being on stage,
it was just the idea
that I'm involved somehow
in leading a group of people to
feel something at the same time,
I thought that was really cool.
That's what I kind of dissected.
'Cause I was doing a lot of things.
I was equally interested in a lot of
different things besides just music.
And so a lot of people are wondering,
why would you not want to be on
a big stage doing all this stuff?
And I just, God, do I Instagram this?
Am I supposed to go on
Instagram and tell you
all these things that I feel about--
You know, I don't.
But really what it boils down to
is I have a pretty wild imagination,
and I have a few set of
skills that I've developed
not only inspiring
artists or leading people
or putting business models to things
or being entrepreneurial
and also understanding,
I'm not really good at any one thing,
but I'm decently good at a
bunch of different things.
I kind of figure, I said,
it might be a really good place for me
to sit in the middle of a bunch of artists
that come together that can do something
a bit more revolutionary than
each artist doing one thing on their own.
That's where that came from.
(steady rock music)
- Lou's Records is a very important place.
It was the most famous
record store in San Diego.
And one of the most famous in the country.
When Blink first started,
I drove around about a 20
mile radius from this store,
and I broke into every
high school at night,
and I made Blink flyers and I put them
in every single locker
at all these high schools
that were playing at the club downtown.
At that point in time,
everyone in San Diego wanted
to support their local bands.
It was just a really big scene.
So because I put those
flyers in those lockers,
we ended up having our
first show at a big club,
all the people came,
and we had enough people that watched us
that the guy that owned the club
invited us the following week
to play on the big stage.
So what we did was not
only played that show,
we rushed in, made a
really quick recording,
and it was our first recording
with a little Buddha statue on it,
people commonly refer to
that record as Buddha.
We made that to sell here in this store.
So we would put five tapes in at a time,
it was in a time where tapes were selling.
And every week we would call up,
and there like, they're gone.
And we're like oh my God, so
we put five more, they're gone.
So then we gave them 10, they're gone.
Them we gave them 20, next thing you know,
we've sold thousands
of these tape cassettes
out of Lou's Records, and
then we got our start.
It was, you know, little suburban kids.
We had a dream to be in
the punk rock section,
and I'm here now looking at
all these things I grew up on,
and it was so insanely important to me.
My inspiration usually comes from,
once the music for the
song is more or less
close to being completed,
I'll just try and find an emotional
current in it that makes sense.
I'll either identify with is
and write exactly like it,
or try to write the opposite.
It's a good question,
because I think it's
different for every artist.
You know they always say, you
know, I write the words first.
But not for myself, I like
to write the music first,
'cause that to me is
like the foundation of
the building you build on top of it.
- How much have you changed
as a creative person?
- Oh a lot.
Well I'm learning so much.
I mean I'm learning so much.
When I come up with a good
idea, I stick with it.
That's the difference.
I can come up with a lot
of ideas, but anyone can.
When I come up with something, you know,
this is something that's capable of
me growing and I still will like this.
You know? (laughing)
This is something that's big
enough and ambitious enough
that in four years from now,
if I really want to
become a space engineer
and build space ships,
I could probably put those
space ships in the movie
or in the book or something, you know?
That's kind of how I think.
Come up with projects that
can last long time and grow,
and then as I grow,
I'm still interested in what I've created.
So yeah, but I plan for that.
I plan for my evolving ideas.
I think my biggest issue is I don't
actively go out and search
for admiration from people.
Or to explain what I'm thinking to people.
Or to validate my actions.
It's the first rule in politics,
you're suppose to define
the other candidate for them
before they can define themselves.
And what happens to me is that the fans,
the good and the bad and
the good and the bad press,
they have defined before
I go out there and do it.
And what's happened is they've
defined me in such a way,
probably in many places,
that is inaccurate.
You know, I don't think people know that
I listen to scholars every
single night before I go to bed.
I put it on my night stand
and listen to lectures,
I don't think people know
that I read books on physics.
I don't think people know that I'm
totally still by fascinated
by (censored) jokes (laughs)
even though I'm doing some
of those things, you know?
I don't think people know
that my favorite thing
in the world outside
of being with my family
is sitting with my Great
Dane and my German Shepherd
at dog beach, you know?
And looking at the sunset.
I don't think people know that
I'm still completely
fascinated with skateboarding.
And my son is so into baseball
that my way of relating to
both is relating Nike SB,
which is Nike Skateboarding.
I don't think people know that's why
I'm wearing Nike in
certain Instagram posts.
Because it's a way for me
to connect with my boy,
but also still have a foot in the
skateboarding world from which I came.
I don't think people know
that I'm completely immersed
in trying to understand ancient religions,
and you know why we are the way we are,
and why we're warring with each other.
And they probably don't know that I think
I a (censored) solution. (laughs)
I'm one of those guys that likes to
look at the biggest ever thing and go,
I bet you I have way to fix it!
Which is the biggest joke ever,
but that's how my brain thinks.
The only thing that takes me away from
my maddening thoughts is
if I'm learning something.
For me what I do is I learn something
and how do I turn that
into an art project?
So it's a non-fiction book or it's
a documentary or it's a lecture,
and what does that look
like as an animation?
What does that look like as a song?
What does that look
like as a feature film?
What does that look like as a story
that has all those things in it?
That's a challenge.
And that keeps my mind at ease.
I used to tell Mark in
Blink that I admired him
because he was always
satisfied with Blink.
It satisfied him, that it
was an incredible thing,
and we were given such
an incredible thing,
and we were so lucky to have it,
and all these different things.
And I agreed with all those things,
but for some reason it's
not stopping my desire
to go out and learn more and try more
and push myself more and be surrounded by
other people who I find
are completely fascinating.
You know, you're not
going to see me do things
that are the easy play.
It's just not going to happen, you know?
You're going to see me do things that
I have no business doing.
And sometimes it's music,
sometimes it's novels,
sometimes it's feature
films or animations,
sometimes it's all those things.
But at the end of the day I'm still just
a very normal kid from a broken family
in a shitty little suburban town,
and that should just prove to everybody
that they can do it too.
("What's My Age Again" by Blink 182)
- When it comes to tattooing,
there's definitely been a learning curve.
I didn't start out a master of my craft.
(laughter)
Between a tattoo artist and his client,
communication is essential.
All right man, it's
all done, check it out.
- I wanted a ship!
- Oh, with a P.
This is with a T.
This is (censored), it's more you.
Some people compare me to Monet,
some to Manet, some to Picasso.
But I think I've developed
a style all my own.
All right, tell me what
you think of this one here.
- What the (censored)?
(tattoo gun buzzing)
(groaning in pain)
- Art is a journey, not a destination.
I'd never want to be perfect,
that's a dead end street.
All right we're all done,
take a look at that,
tell me what you think.
- Binkl 182?
I'll see you in hell!
(audience cheering)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Hyperspree asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
check out the link in the description
and you can go and cast your vote.
I'd also love to know which clip
resonated the most with you,
what lesson are you going
to take from this video,
and immediately apply to your life
or to your business somehow.
Leave it down in the comments below,
I'm really curious to find
out what you have to say.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Jason Fonceca and Yuki.
Thank you guys so much for picking up
a copy of my book at the bookstore
and posting that picture
to your social channels.
I really appreciate the support,
and I'm really glad that you
enjoyed the read through.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
- You should follow
your passions, you know?
And you should make sure
you do something you love.
That's all I've learned,
is that if you're doing
something you love,
you'll work harder at
it and make it happen.
Promise you that.
I actually take feedback really well,
but I think it has to be from--
You have to be with people you respect,
in that you really genuinely think
that they make good decisions, you know?
It's so much easier when
you can trust the person.
When that person looks
me in the eye and says,
it kind of sucks what you just did.
You go, (censored) he means it,
and you know I agree with him.
You know?
And that's where it works.
So you have to, you know,
you have to get people
that you really respect,
that you've built up the trust,
and you empower each other and you can
really really get it done.
And strong debate is a part of it.
If you have intelligent
individuals, it's not hard.